it's Canada's secret shame an epidemic
of missing and murdered indigenous women
and girls indigenous women face a murder
rate six times the national average
every time you come out to this river
do you wonder if you'll recover her body
they come across remains and you don't
know if they're human or not or if
they're your sister
the UN has censured Canada for its
ongoing failure to address the crisis
the march is to send a message to the
men who prey on them that they're being
watched by the community we see what's
going on these guys do not discriminate
they go after anybody and everybody now
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau's
government is taking action those
touched by this national tragedy have
waited but after years of failure on the
part of the police and the government
many here questioned if it could
possibly go far enough to bring justice
for the families and keep women safe it
flashed through my mind that it could be
a body that we were trying to pull up
we're in Winnipeg which is one of the
most violent cities in Canada it also
has the largest urban indigenous
population in North America and more
indigenous women have gone missing or
been murdered here than anywhere else in
the country the Royal Canadian Mounted
Police or RCMP says nearly 1,200
indigenous women have gone missing or
been murdered across Canada since 1980
but advocacy groups put the figure far
higher at about 4,000 women Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau's predecessor
Stephen Harper largely dismissed the
issue then in 2015
Trudeau announced the creation of a
two-year national inquiry to examine the
epidemic as part of what he called a
total renewal of Canada's relationship
with its indigenous people but the
inquiry has been plagued by delays
resignations and allegations of
government interference many here feel
it may be destined to fail Bernadette
Smith's younger sister Claudette Osborne
tayo has been missing since 2008
Bernadette started dragged the red in
2014 to support other families looking
for answers after the bodies of several
women were found in the Red River the
group uses homemade dragging bars with
built-in hooks to search the bottom of
the river they hand over what they find
to police and a team of forensic
anthropologists every time we go out we
offer tobacco to give thanks for you
know being able to be out here and do
this work but also to offer prayers to
you know the families that are missing
someone that don't have answers
or who had been murdered and nobody's
been brought to justice why this fine
particular so this was the Alexander
dock so there was two young girls that
were found here in August 2014 the body
of a 15 year old indigenous girl named
Tina Fontaine was found in this river
wrapped in plastic
Tina's death was a turning point that
opened up a lot of people's eyes to this
epidemic and sent shockwaves across the
country for many it highlighted the
failures of the system in the hours
before her death she encountered the
police hospital staff and child welfare
workers
tell me about your sister and how she
went missing I know she was only 21 at
the time 10 years ago she'd been
sexually abused when she was 12 and
started running away from home and she
ended up with much older man and was
exploited and was pushed on to the
streets Claudette wasn't someone who
didn't stay in contact with someone
daily nobody had heard from her in two
days so my sister Tina went and she
filed a missing-persons report and the
police basically said you know she's out
there somewhere just give it a few days
and we kept going back to the police
station and saying like you know
something's wrong they would didn't take
us seriously they didn't investigate her
case for 10 days well yeah so there's a
prime example that's what they pulled up
so there's no blood on it yeah we pull
up clothing all the time he's pulled up
lots of underwear women's underwear and
people wait to body found with cement
right when they found Tina Fontaine's
body she was weighted down yeah
oh wow that's a strong tug that's just
something something that's yeah
something definitely it got caught on
here
[Music]
Jesus Christ I have liked
so that's the boot more cloth possibly
clothing
buuut
it looks like there's a white
remains inside you want me to check for
a foot I think they're telling me
they're telling me to check for a foot
in here instead of branch
it flashed through my mind that it could
be a body that we were trying to pull up
and it made me feel sick to my stomach
thinking that's what you guys are here
to do our first year there were seven
bodies recovered from this river so
every year we've helped and I don't even
know how many your sister went missing
ten years ago every time you come out to
this river
do you wonder if you'll recover her body
yeah yep definitely that's
that's a reality you come across remains
and you don't know if they're human or
not or if they're your sister like it's
an emotional rollercoaster because you
just never know three other women in
Bernadette's family have gone missing or
been murdered only one case has been
solved should it be the police doing
this absolutely it should be policing is
an issue in this country we were on the
streets putting up posters talking to
people going to different organizations
going to different places we knew caught
at went to you know we were basically
doing the police job for them and no
family shouldn't have to do that the
Winnipeg Police declined to speak with
us on camera or give us a statement
[Music]
Mikell champagne is an activist who
organizes weekly anti violence rallies
in Winnipeg's primarily indigenous north
and neighborhood a new mural dedicated
to missing and murdered women has just
been painted in this weekly meeting
place I wanted to know why it was
necessary to hold weekly anti violence
rallies here there was a time when in a
year we had over 52 vigils funerals
hospital room visits and are the same
group people got together but always
centered around the negative things we
need to hosts weekly anti violence
here's to send a message not only to the
community but to the people that prey on
our community and our message is that we
are united
Michael grew up in the child welfare
system here and says that one out of six
children in this neighborhood are
currently in the care of the system
seven percent of children across Canada
are indigenous but they make up nearly
half of all foster children in the
country the government cites poverty or
lack of adequate food or housing as
reasons for separating them from their
birth families what connections do you
see between the child welfare system and
the epidemic of missing and murdered
indigenous women in the child welfare
system often what ends up happening is a
devaluing of indigenous life especially
for indigenous women and girls as they
age out of care they turn 18 unequipped
with life skills separate from their
biological families or their home
communities they're at risk of
homelessness harmful substance use
sexual exploitation part of the reason
why we have such difficulties in child
welfare today is that many of those
children right now are actually children
like me of Indian Residential school
survivors from the 1840s to the
mid-1990s some 150,000 indigenous
children were removed from their
families and sent to church and
government-run Indian Residential
schools their aim was to kill the Indian
in the child by assimilating them into
dominant Canadian culture many children
suffered emotional physical and sexual
abuse while attending these schools as
we know now Indian Residential schools
was a failed experiment that did a lot
more harm than it did good
and unfortunately that that history of
family separation over so many
generations continues to this day with
child welfare
12:30 a.m. here in the North End
neighborhood and Winnipeg and we've
joined this Midnight medicine walk
organized by the community to reach out
to women here that are being sexually
exploited to offer them prayers and
medicine and let them know that they're
being watched after and also the marches
to send a message to the men who prey on
them that they're being watched by the
community Lauren show Peck is the
founder of the walk she was once a
missing indigenous woman herself
Lauren ran away from home as a teenager
and was trafficked on these streets
where she narrowly escaped a serial
killer how did the idea of the midnight
medicine walk come about
I own it
being exploited I wanted to do something
to acknowledge those people as really
actually really are and acknowledge
their experience on earnest
just walking past them everyday
or diet path with them every day
thinking of them as homeless people
because that's not where they are tell
me about some of the interactions you
have with these women that you're
reaching out to on the streets and what
really sticks with you they tear up
those women because they're finally
being recognized and they might not feel
like they deserve that
that's kind of standing ovations that we
give them and we stopped everything
before them as much they feel like they
don't deserve it what they do and
they're finally being a pay attention to
is this process really healing for you
it is it is really feeling for me out of
all those negative experiences I had as
the young girl being sexually exploited
now people recognize me and they respect
me for those things I guess but like in
a different way because now I I turned
it into something beautiful I guess as
we turned the corner onto the main
boulevard we were told that no one takes
this road at night unless they're
looking for sex what message are you
guys sending to the men out there who
prey on this vulnerability that we see
what's going on I don't know we don't
believe that our people deserve it I
want to see the community coming
together
because the police's response has been
insufficient indigenous activists have
been stepping up in various ways to
ensure the safety of their community
members and streets okay so two groups
of seven yep we've got 14 right James
Fievel is the executive director of the
bear clan Patrol a Community Safety
Patrol that operates in some of
Winnipeg's toughest neighborhoods five
to six nights a week when we talk about
the epidemic of missing and murdered
indigenous women and girls here in this
country do you see your work as trying
to put an end to that and that's exactly
why we started in the wake of what
happen with Tina Fontaine I just wasn't
prepared to sit around and watch anymore
I had to do something so I could at
least sleep at night and my country's be
clear and so we started out with twelve
volunteers and in 2014 and now we have
200 how does that make you feel pretty
tell me a little bit more about the
sexual exploitation you see on these
streets well I mean it's yeah the
prostitution you know it's it was
pervasive for a very long time and there
was no nobody doing anything about it it
was like it was permitted in this area
you know and for for us and here in this
community that's not that's not suitable
right we have we have the exploited
women you know standing up against
buddies fence you know and the kids are
playing in the yard and we've got John's
coming and these guys do not
discriminate they go after anybody and
everybody they don't care if you're ten
years old or if you're 40 years old why
hasn't the state or the city done more
to crack down on these John's and
political will is not there Canada's
national inquiry into missing and
murdered indigenous women and girls is
expected to conclude in April of 2019
the inquiry is examining the systemic
causes of violence against indigenous
women and girls and making
recommendations for how to keep them
safe at a cost of fifty three point
eight million dollars during our time in
Winnipeg we heard from those who feel
the inquiry may not be up to the task
our family didn't participate in that
inquiry we called for a National Action
Plan you know women are still going
missing they're still being murdered and
there's no really resources or
prevention put in place to stop that
from happening
I feel like this inquiry needs to be led
by experiential family members that
actually know what it's like to lose a
loved one so that we have an appropriate
amount of urgency behind the work that
we're doing
Tasha spilitt is an academic and
educator who's been following the
inquiry I don't see that there will be
any outcome in it unless there's real
legal teeth from that from that inquiry'
in 50 years another one in a hundred
years another one in a hundred and fifty
years if we don't understand that at the
bottom of this is a really harmful power
dynamic in which indigenous women and
girls are situated at the bottom we
wanted to take these concerns to prime
minister justin trudeau
but his office declined our request for
an interview instead they directed us to
Carolyn Bennett the minister of crown
indigenous relations for months we
reached out to her office for an
interview and eventually received a
statement that stresses the government's
commitment to in their words end this
national tragedy and lists the
initiatives it's taking to support
affected communities and prevent future
violence in the meantime as Canada's
government struggles to repair its
relationship with its indigenous
population the communities here are
continuing to search for their missing
women while trying to stop the next one
from being murdered we've made it part
of Claudette's legacy to help other
families to do whatever we can to create
awareness to
so under her yeah hey everyone its Deena
so how much did you know about the
epidemic of missing and murdered
indigenous women and girls let me know
in the comments and be sure to check out
our next direct from episode where I
travel to British Columbia to report on
the fight against the trans mountain
pipeline make sure to like and share
this video and subscribe to aj+